probably the loudest sound i ever heard
was uh have you guys ever had like
lightning strikes like hit really close
yeah no actually no really like you
could feel
the shockwave yeah at that point so i i
had one moment where like i
legitimately thought i was gonna die but
um it was in high school
and like ow that the front part of our
school has this like big courtyard
looking thing like and
it's kind of on an uphill climb so if
you're standing like right at the top of
the hill and look
you can basically look across the
entirety of the school
which is kind of cool so then me and my
couple of my friends were there and it
was like
very lightly raining and you could hear
thunder off in the distance but it
wasn't like
a thunderstorm right so everybody was
outside just kind of chilling
and we had this like one really massive
pine tree i want to say it's maybe like
you know 15 20 meter tall pine tree it's
huge just like
on the other side of the school right
and i was looking at it for some reason
just kind of like waiting for the bus
just like what a beautiful pineapple
yeah no no like because it's so massive
that you know it basically just fills up
your entire view
yeah and then all of a sudden it was
just this like flash of white
and this the largest [ __ ] crashing
sound i've ever [ __ ] heard
and what turned out was a lightning bolt
had struck that pine tree
yeah that pine tree was probably only
about like 20 meters away from me
oh wow but it was [ __ ] massive and it
was crazy as well because like
we're at the top of the hill so you can
see all the other students across the
courtyard
and everybody simultaneously was like
like that
yeah i [ __ ] myself yeah yeah and but it
was so weird because
that entire crash happened and for like
20 seconds the entire courtyard was just
silent
and we're kind of just like standing
right and then [ __ ] seventh grader
like you know kids over
whose balls haven't dropped you ever
suddenly like
just got [ __ ] shell-shocked i know
this is [ __ ] there's just a [ __ ]
panic across the school
all the teachers like [ __ ]
themselves the tree was on fire
yeah so like straight up it was just
like a fire
this 20 meter tall pine tree was just on
fire
satanic but it was crazy because it was
like it from
i'd say between a five minute span of no
sorry five second span
it went from beautiful large pine tree
to just
a burning 20 meter long
[ __ ] crazy damn it really was scary i
mean again like that was probably
i i thought i was going to go deaf
because that was it was so
[ __ ] loud it was insanely like the
other loudest sound i've ever heard
was um clap my ass yeah
of course you can't you can't escape
from me snake but
um the other one was we were playing
cricket
obviously of course as as the audience
give me some animation yeah
we're playing cricket and uh have you
ever felt like how hard a cricket ball
is
yes yeah that thing is [ __ ] hot it's
like a rock basically
yeah it is a solid piece of whatever it
is but um
we were playing qriket in school and uh
i was in the outfield
and one of the kids like kind of smacked
it really really high up into the air
and it was going towards one of my
friends and he was underneath he was
ready to catch it
it's like come on catch your catch and
catch it but i think he mistimed it
because the sun was in his eyes or
something
so the cricket ball landed right on his
phone oh
god the only way i can describe this
sound was as if
someone in the distance had slapped two
pieces of wood together
it was just like this clark sound
and the kid just dropped to the floor
like we straight up thought he died
because he just that [ __ ] is hard right
was that like the [ __ ] mortal kombat
moment where you know like
like the [ __ ] skeleton
it's like a [ __ ] fatality right
honestly because
it just it went crack on his forehead
and he
he literally just dropped the fall right
and he was fine like he had he had like
a massive bruise on his head but he
and this man's got a dummy thicker yeah
we straight up thought he died we're
like oh my god